it's the third installment of the
fantastic beasts franchise and the cast
and crew of secrets of dumbledore are
not pulling any spells on this one from
brand new locations to funny crab dances
we've got the magical scoop you need to
know about this adventure hold on tight
muggles
number one everyone who grew up on the
harry potter films dreams of being able
to step foot onto the magical sets and
now that it was time to dust off the
floating candles the cast of fantastic
beasts were living the dream that
nostalgia that everyone has gets in my
dna as it is for a lot of people the
classic spell casting and locations from
the original films were enough to excite
the cast these films have a place in
people's lives it takes you right back
to the potters it's hard to imagine how
these potter nerds were able to keep
cool on set but when nerds unite well
that's when the magic happens everybody
around you
is as excited as you are number two the
fantastic beasts franchise brought all
new locations to the table being able to
open up the magical world to completely
new areas set designers traveled across
the world to get new inspirations we get
a new look at some of the inner rooms of
hogwarts and hogsmeade got quite the
upgrade as well they've created this
battered beautiful old pub set designers
really went all out when it came to
details down to the fires and decor i
really wanted to just grab a drink and
sit down by the fire it was so authentic
we can't imagine being right in the
middle of those classic potter sets but
the most important place of all was the
great hall being able to shoot in the
great hall is very special he felt very
harry pottery
number three every harry potter-like
film has got to have the best visual
effects and we became so accustomed to
those beautifully designed spells and
complex creatures from the original
films but visual effects artists were a
little more motivated to beat their
predecessors one of the things i love
about these movies they have pure
spectacle artists specifically wanted to
out affect the order of the phoenix a
film that really changed the game and
spell casting for the rest of the
franchise i don't think we've seen magic
done as well as that since from the look
of the trailers we're sure they didn't
hold back on this one
number four having an extremely talented
group of actors means the improv on set
is gonna be good it's no secret that a
film's process would incorporate
improvisation from its actors regularly
but how would they do it when magic is
involved when you get to incorporate
magic into that as well or creatures
that for me is has been some of the most
fun it seems director david yates really
trusted this group and kind of allowed
them to direct the visual effects he
would allow us as actors the freedoms
come up with new ideas
number five the effects we see in the
final product can be achieved in a
number of different ways most of the
time before the shot reaches
post-production the actors can look a
little ridiculous this was in fact true
for eddie redmayne as he posed for this
photo very hard to act real in this
scene but take it for fact from co-star
jude law
he's brilliant acting comes in
you'd probably think we're lying with
this next vfx story so we'll just let
eddie kick it off for us i was sort of
lying on this big green cloth that was
being pumped so a little context newt
comforts an injured creature in the rain
and being that there's no real life
creature of the magical sort they just
had to get creative i love i love that
you know they fit hopefully it'll feel
really emotional number six we've got a
thief on our hands and who else other
than newt scamander himself
i did yeah i did steal
it eddie admitted to it alongside jude
law during an interview but he had his
reasons the case was so beautiful and
the interior of it had
drawings of the creatures he found his
opportunity from a little charm casted
by dumbledore we were not told the exact
situation unfortunately we guess the law
was worked around with a little magic
news case is multiplied yeah
it's basically saying there are a few
cases number seven all beloved
franchises keep their stories secret
before their release but what does the
cast know we think they'd have to know
something right do you hear that this
time you might be going to um so lots of
sort of rumors would find themselves as
far as filmmakers allowed the actors to
go was a script-by-script basis the
actors had no clue what their
character's ultimate endings would be
but they did get small hints as to what
would happen in the next film
occasionally we would get snippets of
what might be coming up in the next
films
number eight fans may be a little
weirded out to see a new dumbledore and
this time he's going to be a very
underdeveloped character he's not the
fully formed dumbledore of the harry
potter books and films law's
interpretation of the character is
supposed to be a take on before he
obtained the wisdom we know from the
classical interpretations of richard
harris and michael gambin albus is
getting his affairs in order on this one
and who better to join the dumbledore
legacy than jude law he's a man still
finding his way still resolving his
demons
number nine as johnny depp's abrupt
departure from the beast franchise
caused a lot of uncertainty someone had
to step in as his replacement luckily
mads mikkelsen was able to quickly fill
the shoes and he was rushed to do it my
journey was fast the swift but i felt at
home right away but he fit right in with
the cast and jumping in with good
chemistry is no easy task although his
time was short mads really made a small
family out of the cast it's a family you
visit and you just can only hope that
they will adopt you number 10 a trilogy
requires new members of the cast and
along with mads came the great jessica
williams who plays professor lally hicks
we get to introduce jess in a great way
in a bigger way as most of the
characters at the beginning of the
franchise were new it was exciting to
see a teaser in the second film of
william's new character she is such a
big fan of the potter franchise that
this role was just a dream come true for
her it's a story and world that's been
imprinted in my life since childhood
number 11 oh we don't think eddie will
ever be able to live this one down it
all stems from the a rumpant mating
dance in the first movie and the process
behind this complex crab dance is even
more hilarious oh and how could this be
and let's look at real wildlife programs
poor newt really thought filmmakers had
it out for him and the way it turned out
we wonder if they got a good laugh out
of this too it's basically the eddie
makes a tool of himself a scene
number 12 there's always that one
goofball cast member and we bet you will
never guess who it was for this film i
think maths is quite funny
not an easy title to earn during a quick
film time and he didn't even know he was
being that funny i wasn't trying to i
was trying to be terrifying
number 13 the actual comic relief of the
film the only muggle dan fogler was
really too busy obsessing over his new
wand to crack jokes offset i was handed
a lightsaber you know for me that's huge
he was so emotional over fighting with
one that he geeked out like the rest of
us would and by the look of the trailers
he seems to have gotten the hang of it
it was just great uh just having it
holding it putting in my pocket number
14 to wrap this one up let's get the
tears going it's hard to believe
director david yates being a part of the
harry potter franchise for so long and
really creating lifelong families out of
the cast it's a very fond memory of the
many wonderfully creative people i've
worked with he's made films that
incorporate magic into friendships so
beautifully but always new to pick the
best actors and crew to bring it to life
on screen we know family is everything
in the wizarding world and now we have
to accept some new siblings to the group
how could we have ever expected such a
group of adventurers to get so
mischievous behind the scenes what was
your favorite behind the scenes moment
of the secrets of dumbledore let us know
in the comments